[Music]
hey good news just a couple of days from
now most of us are going to have a week
of vacation isn't that nice I plan to
spend my entire week watching The Hobbit
[Applause]
I hope I'll have enough time yeah
someone told me it's something like
sixty four hours long you actually
watched them grow and die in real time I
can't wait to go see that bring plenty
of water with me
good news for President Obama Time
magazine has named President Obama the
Person of the Year
[Applause]
[Music]
the editor said they gave it to Obama
for winning re-election passing Obama
care and being the last person in
America to subscribe to Time magazine
he's the last one you know who was
number two for Person of the Year
no Nicolas Cage at his vote Hillary
Clinton is recovering from her
concussion and she's doing fine doing
well some conservatives though are
accusing Hillary Clinton of faking her
concussion can you believe that yeah
Bill Clinton defended her saying hey
when Hillary fakes something I know it
[Applause]
these are the moves I do now have to
Isaiah ya sing the founder of Domino's
Pizza is suing the government because he
says Obamacare goes against his pro-life
principles
yeah the Domino's founder said I believe
life begins at conception and ends with
a heart attack at 59 life cycle hey I
couldn't believe this Iran's supreme
leader Ayatollah Khomeini has joined
Facebook yes Ayatollah how many has
joined Facebook yeah and you thought
Facebook was over when your parents
joined it works the same like if you're
having a party like the ayatollahs here
yeah let's get out you just poked me
he wrote some stuff on my wall according
to a new study that just came out people
with type 2 diabetes can reverse their
condition with proper diet and lots of
exercise yeah yeah so yeah so in other
words America is still no closer to a
cure ain't gonna work
sloppy joe eating sloppy joe a mime is
not supposed to tell what it was right
after he does good thing that's what
this mine does in a box in a box a box
sloppy joe now thank you please thank
you historians now think that the
ancient Egyptian pharaoh ramses the
third who ruled 3,000 years ago was
actually murdered yeah police are
currently questioning the prime suspect
Larry King
[Applause]
back then he was Larry King Tut
[Applause]
hey gang at a zoo in China a tropical
bird a tropical bird at a zoo in China a
tropical bird has been shouting fu had
all the visitors in a related story
quentin tarantino's parents missing this
is a really crazy story not like that
one wasn't but in South Carolina this is
true a man was arrested for stealing a
blow-up doll of Miley Cyrus yeah
however the man's alibi is that at the
time of the robbery he was at home with
his wife
styrofoam Jessica Simpson